the concept of being triggered though it
may at times be overused sits on top of
a hugely important Concept in
psychological life which demands our
respect compassion and attention
to be triggered is in its most basic
form to respond with intense fear and
anger to a situation in the here and now
which to other people may seem blameless
and unconcerning
one moment we are calm the next we're
catapulted into Despair and Terror only
minutes ago the future looked hopeful
now only ruin and disaster seem to lie
ahead
most of us who suffer from these
episodes would very much like to better
hold on to calm and Hope
it may be important to know how to be
scared or angry when situations actually
demand it but the triggered person
typically feels after an episode it's
also deeply counterproductive and just
plain exhausting to be visited by
powerful emotions that aren't warranted
by what lies before us and that fail to
advance our interests in any way
the way out of being uncontrollably
triggered is to understand how the
mechanism operates the mind is triggered
when it believes that it recognizes in
the world around it a situation that it
feels from memory is going to be highly
damaging and dangerous our triggers are
a secret guide to our own private
histories they tell us about things that
we were once very afraid of the
triggering element is like a piece of a
jigsaw that will precisely fit into an
analogous puzzle in the past we are
triggered Now by what we were devastated
by then even if we don't remember too
much about our past we can guess
everything we need to know from reverse
engineering our triggers if we're
constantly afraid we're going to be
excommunicated and mocked this will in
some form be exactly what happened to us
at some stage long ago if we're
terrified that someone is going to
overpower us and not listen to our nose
this is an almost sure of what we once
experienced
the precise relationship between Trigger
and catalytic event may not always be
literally equivalent there can be some
displacement along the way but the link
will be strong all the same the trigger
contains and maps onto a traumatic event
let's imagine a person who is triggered
that is thrown into powerful Despair and
self-loathing by images on social media
of blatantly attractive and popular
people no sooner have they seen these
then they start to doubt and despise
themselves reflect on their inadequacies
and remember all the reasons why they
are fated to be a failure and unloved
the trigger is not entirely nothing
there is something a little bit
dispiriting about the beauty parade on
certain sorts of social media but the
pointed issue is the scale of the
reaction that is generated in seeking to
account for it we've got to Look
Backwards the person has been triggered
because the Contemporary event contains
in a garbled disguised and unconscious
form the essence of a profoundly
traumatic dynamic in earlier life which
lies mostly unknown and unexplored and
thereby commands immense an unending
power over the victim
let's suppose that this person had a
mother who favored their more Rebellion
younger sibling over them and that their
looks were part of what damned them to
horrible neglect and emotional coldness
it doesn't in the circumstances take
much to be returned back to this Bleak
place we are animals who are primed to
sniff out in the present the slightest
sign of the dangers of the past the
tragedy of triggering is that it fails
to notice the differences between then
and now between the awfulness we
suffered long ago and the relative
innocence of the modern moment insofar
as bad things do happen nowadays
triggering also fails to account for the
way in which we're no longer children
and are therefore able to respond to the
threats that do come our way with a lot
more creativity strength and calm than
we possessed as 4 or 10 year olds with
things ever to get as bad as they once
were we have so many more options than
we did and therefore so many reasons to
feel less agitated and
to be triggered is to lose our powers of
discrimination in the Heat of the Moment
We can no longer distinguish between A
and B so frightening is a that
everything between it and Q is at Heart
Another a we can't tell that someone is
not telling us that we're guilty that
the situation isn't evidence of Doom
that we're not being mocked that our
colleague isn't attacking us that we
aren't being reprimanded unbearably that
we haven't been told we're an idiot or a
monster we can't distinguish between
looking a bit tired and looking
fundamentally unacceptable between
something they've done that got them
sent to prison and something that we've
done that won't ever be noticed so
primed as our history made us to
appalling scenarios we have no ability
not to refine them at every turn
especially when we're a bit low or a bit
tired
though we might assume that we'd want to
escape our triggers we are also often
drawn to them through a compulsive sense
of familiarity calm and confidence
aren't our resting places they don't
feel normal and are therefore worrying
in their own way we want our awful
hunches confirmed it can feel right to
put ourselves in environments where
people might be mocking to look out for
stories of disgrace or ruin or to
befriend people who are constantly on
the edge of harming us
the cure for triggering is love love
understood as a process of patiently
holding someone and like a kindly and
soothing parent helping them to
discriminate between black and white
Terror and calm evil and goodness the
Cure lies to in learning how to work
backwards from our current triggers to
understanding the Dynamics that once
created them rather than worrying yet
again about the future we should ask
ourselves a simple question what does my
fear of what will happen tell me about
what did happen What scenario from my
past is contained in my alarm at the
future
to overcome our triggers is to come to
navigate the present with all the
confidence and excited curiosity that
should have been Ours from the start and
maturity could be defined as knowing
what triggers us and why and a
commitment to dampening our first
responses in the name of a patient
exploration and understanding of our own
histories